in good shape your weekly dose of health
information on deutsche welle find out
more about what's new in medical
treatment alternative medicine as well
as nutrition wellness and beauty medical
professionals therapists and counselors
are in our studio to offer their expert
advice on in good shape my guest in this
to do today has saved many a marriage
probably by helping the senora's dr.
thomas pencil thank you very much for
coming here today hello thanks you for
inviting me dr. pencil you're an expert
on sleeping disorders from that point of
view what is the most common reason for
snoring what causes that abstraction in
the airways well the main reason for
snoring is to collapse the airway the
collapsible airway which is typical for
humans and the nurse at a certain age
don't work as proper as in young age so
it's that's genetic that our Airways
tend to collapse when we sleep or the
tissue vibrates then in the breast
basically but there are other factors I
guess that induce snoring many of our
viewers have written to ask about that
like Alex sica from France wants to know
why he snows when he lies on his back
and not when he lies on his side yes
many reasons which are a v8 snarling so
positional snoring lying on the back is
indeed one of their graduating factors
but not everyone knows when being on the
back some people tend to snow in any
body position but others in just on the
back and there are other reasons other
reasons our obesity fatty tissue and
smoking also so there are a number of
other factors too so those are factors
that you can influence you can lose
weight you can stop smoking to try and
better your snoring and we'll speak a
bit more about other therapies later on
let's speak focus on on children now
children sometimes snore is that
something they'll just grow out of oh
yes children also snore
that's very important and parents can
recognize that if the children fall
asleep during day time if they don't
perform at school as well if they are
tired and there's nothing is often the
cause of big tongue fields and for that
it is important that investigations are
done by an ENT physician looking at tons
it and something can be done definitely
so you should get an ear nose and throat
doctor to look at that if your child
snores snoring can also be a sign of a
more serious underlying condition can
you tell us a bit more about that
snoring is in our medical terms
something like a precursor of sleep
apnea if the snarling which is annoying
for the bed partner mainly and often
snoring this sleep disorder for the bed
partner more than farthest Nava well if
the snarling becomes irregular and if
this knowing is interrupted by breathing
pauses best of just by the bed partner
then it becomes dangerous those
breathing pauses they are typically 10
to 60 seconds each and they may be as
repetitive up to 300 breathing pauses
during the night we call the sleep apnea
so in that case you don't get enough
oxygen and that can cause serious
problems and you should get it checked
out right yes sleep apnea is a very
important disorder with lots of
consequences like sleepiness and type
attention dr. pencil what would you say
when is surgery really the best option
for a snorer surgery is a good option if
there are large tongue fields and if
there's a lot of floppy tissue but in
general unfortunately those surgical
options they are not very effective only
in half of the patient it really helps
and they really improve the symptoms
only by fifty percent so it's a problem
what other forms of treatment are there
that you could try well we think that
surgical options are third line first
line is definitely
something like a ventilation therapy
with the mask we call the CPAP second is
some tongue based jaw transmen so that
can be done by a dentist and only
thought may be an option of surgical
options well there are many treatments
out on the market or available and let's
go through them and see what's your view
there if they effective or not what
about sleeping pillows special pillows
for senora's yes they are quite popular
sleeping pillows or some West's in order
to avoid the back position they may help
to reduce the noise and to some extent
the snarling if the snoring is on the
back side but as not all people only
snow on the backside it's only effective
in a few parts and a few people what
about anti snore spray does that help
well aunt is north quay we actually
evaluated some years ago and look for
the effects it's some kind of moisture
and in their power base and it seems to
lower the noise a little bit but it does
not extinguish snoring at all and the no
straps do they help the no step somehow
make the nose of wider so there is some
positive effect we know this also from
sports from running people that there's
a more effective nose breathing but for
the snarling which happens in there and
the back of the throat it doesn't help
that much okay um well what's what can
give some hope to snores is there
anything that's being researched any new
methods out there that we can wait for
hope for yes we are still looking for
new medications for new drugs again
snoring and the one who will find that
it will become a millionaire no doubt
unfortunately that has not been found
and we also look for new therapies for
sleep apnea there are kind of pacemakers
which are implanted here and which have
to put truth the tongue and by that
opendir paribas so some options under
Laura's own alright well let's
for that hope for that thank you for
being our guest thanks for you thank you
very much
you